FOR ALMOST 40 YEARS NOW I HAVE
BEEN VOTING REPUBLICAN.
I DON'T KNOW THAN I HAVE EVER
VOTED FOR A DEMOCRAT.
AS REPUBLICANS, THERE HAS TO BE
CONSEQUENCES AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR THOSE THAT WE CAN
TRUST AND DEPEND ON TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND UPHOLD THEIR
OATHS.
>> THAT WAS LIZ CHENEY LAST
MONTH, CALLING ON REPUBLICAN
VOTERS TO REJECT CANDIDATES WHO
REJECT WHO SPREAD LIES ABOUT
ELECTIONS AND IN THE FINAL DAYS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS SHE IS NOT
STOPPING FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN THE DISTRICT, TOM
BARRETT, WHO SAYS THAT HE HAD A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN ABOUT HOW
THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
CONDUCTED.
INSTEAD, YOU WILL SEE CAN LET
CHENEY CAMPAIGNING WITH
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT ALYSSA
SLOTKIN.
ALL IS A SLOTKIN JOINS US NOW.
OUR FIRST QUESTION, DID YOU ASK
LIZ CHENEY TO COME CAMPAIGN
WITH THE OR DID SHE ASK YOU TO
COME A CAMPAIGN?
>> AND GOOD MORNING BY THE WAY!
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, GOOD MORNING.
CONGRATS ON YOUR NEW SHOW.
NO, SHE CAME UP TO ME ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE IN OUR LAST
VOTING WEEK IN SEPTEMBER AND
SHE CHEST SAID, YOU KNOW, LOOK
IF THERE IS ANYTHING I CAN DO
TO HELP YOU LET ME KNOW.
I SAID, REALLY?
AND THAT BEGAN THE
CONVERSATION.
I AM APPRECIATIVE, BECAUSE IT
IS JUST ANOTHER POINT OF
BRAVERY THAT I THINK I REALLY
ADMIRE ABOUT HER.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK MAKES HER
AN EFFECTIVE SURROGATE FOR YOU?
YOU ARE A VULNERABLE DEMOCRAT
IN ONE OF THE MOST COMPETITIVE
SWING DISTRICTS IN AN ELECTION
HAPPENING A WEEK FROM TODAY.
WHAT MAKES HER ANY ELECT AN
EFFECTIVE SURROGATE FOR YOU?
>> I THINK FOR ME IT IS A
REPUBLICAN-LEANING DISTRICT AND
I STILL REALLY BELIEVE IN
PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE THAT EVEN IF THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT I BELIEVE IN, THAT THEY
WANT TO LEADERS WITH INTEGRITY
AND LEADERS WHO DEMONSTRATE
LEADERSHIP.
I THINK THAT LIZ HAS DONE THAT
AND I THINK THAT SHE HAS DONE
THAT EFFECTIVELY.
LOOK, THE LAST TIME THAT SHE
WAS DOING MEDIA IN MY MEDIA
MARKET SHE WAS DISAGREEING WITH
ME VEHEMENTLY ON A POLICY IN
JANUARY OF 2020.
WE AGREE ON ONE REALLY BIG
THING, WHICH IS THAT THERE HAS
TO BE A DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM IN
ORDER FOR OUR SYSTEM TO
FUNCTION.
IT IS PRETTY IMPORTANT TO ME.
>> I THINK THAT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT POINT.
WHEN I HEARD THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING, I THOUGHT, WOW.
THEY ARE REALLY AT DIFFERENT
ENDS OF THE SPECTRUM ON SO MANY
KEY ISSUES.
ONE ABORTION, ALL OBAMA CARE,
IMMIGRATION.
SHE HAS A VERY CONSERVATIVE
VOTING RECORD, RIGHT?
BUT I WANT TO SEE WHAT THAT
SAYS THAT SHE WILL BE ON THE
TRAIL WITH YOU TONIGHT, ABOUT
WHERE YOU PLACE THE IMPORTANCE
OF UPHOLDING DEMOCRACY, REALLY
ABOVE ALL AUS.
BUT YOU CAN DISAGREE ON REALLY
SIGNIFICANT POLICY ISSUES BUT
COME TOGETHER TO UPHOLD
DEMOCRACY.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, LOOK.
THE HISTORY OF DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS IS VOCIFEROUS
DEBATE ABOUT POLICY.
REALLY GOING BACK AND FORTH.
THAT IS MY DREAM, THAT WE ARE
IN A SYSTEM WHERE WE ARE
PUSHING AND PULLING ON EACH
OTHER ABOUT THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT IN OUR LIVES.
THAT IS AS AMERICAN AS APPLE
PIE AND GEORGE WASHINGTON.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A DEMOCRACY,
EACH SIDE JUST SAYS THE OTHER
GUY WHEN I DON'T BELIEVE IN OUR
SYSTEM.
IT IS GOING TO CRUMBLE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
WHILE WE DISAGREE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO DEBATING HER IN THE
FUTURE ON ISSUES OF POLICY,
DEMOCRACY, WE ARE IN VEHEMENT
AGREEMENT.
>> OH.
>> ALL YOU.
>> [LAUGHS]
I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
LIZ CHENEY, SHE IS PROBABLY,
DEMOCRATS PROBABLY LIKE HER NOW
A LOT MORE THAN REPUBLICANS?
DO YOU THINK THAT SHE COULD
POSSIBLY HELP YOU OR HURT YOU
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL?
BECAUSE SHE IS SORT OF TOXIC
FOR REPUBLICANS.
>> I HAVE BEEN ASKED THIS
BEFORE, I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
SORT OF BE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES THAT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANY ONE PERSON WINNING AN
ELECTION.
MY RACE IS GOING TO BE A
NAIL-BITER.
I'VE KNOWN THAT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IT ALWAYS IS.
I AM COMFORTABLE IF THE PEOPLE
OF MY DISTRICT SAY THAT I AM
NOT THE RIGHT PERSON, THEN SO
BE IT.
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN JUST
GETTING REELECTED.
I THINK THAT LEADERSHIP,
PRINCIPLED LEADERSHIP IN THIS
COUNTRY, IS VITAL IF WE ARE
GOING TO GET THROUGH WHATEVER
WE ARE GOING THROUGH RIGHT NOW.
THIS PERIOD OF INSTABILITY.
I'M WILLING TO TAKE THAT RISK
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HIGHLIGHT PEOPLE WHO ARE
BRAVE IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE ARE SO FEW RELIEVER
STANDING UP.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE SPEAKING
TODAY AT THE OFFENSE.
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE VOTING FOR
ME.
HAVE THEM EXPLAIN THEIR CASE.
I THINK THEY REPRESENT A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN THIS DISTRICT LIKE MY
DAD, RIGHT?
WHO WAS A LIFELONG REPUBLICAN
BUT FEELS LIKE THE PARTY HAS
JUST GONE OFF ON THE WRONG
TRACK AND, TO THOSE PEOPLE AND
SPEAKING TO.
MODERATE PUBLICANS,
INDEPENDENTS, PEOPLE WHO KNOW
THAT THIS KIND OF TOXIC ANGER
THAT PEOPLE ARE THROWING BACK
AND FORTH IN THE POLITICAL
REALM IS NOT GOOD FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND THEY WANT LEADER
WHO'S WHO TRY TO RISE ABOVE
THAT.
>> LET ME FOLLOW UP, THAT
HERE'S THE THING, THE CRITICISM
FOR DEMOCRATS IS THAT DEMOCRATS
DON'T HAVE THE BITE THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE AND POLITICS,
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IS ALL
ABOUT WINNING.
IF YOU WIN THEN YOU GET YOUR
POINT ACROSS AND YOU GET TO
ENACT LAWS, LEGISLATION, THE
WHOLE POINT IS TO WIN.
PEOPLE THINK, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FIGHT BECAUSE YOU ARE SAYING,
LOOK --
PEOPLE MAY THINK YOU ARE SAYING
YOU DON'T REALLY WANT TO WIN
BECAUSE OF THE ANSWER YOU JUST
GAVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON
THIS SHOW.
>> WELL, LOOK.
THIS IS GOING TO BE MY THIRD
TOUGH ELECTION.
I THINK I'VE DEMONSTRATED MORE
THAN, FRANKLY, A LOT OF TRUE
BLUE DEMOCRATS IN PLACES LIKE
THE EAST COAST OR WEST COAST,
THAT I NOT ONLY DO I HAVE THE
FIGHT IN ME BUT I ACTUALLY WIND
TOUGH RACES.
THIS ISN'T THE PRIMARY, IT IS A
GENERAL ELECTION.
WE HAVE TIMES MAJORITY RIGHT
NOW BY FOUR OR FIVE SEATS AND I
AM ONE OF THOSE SEATS.
I THINK I'VE DEMONSTRATED A
CAPACITY TO FIGHT AND A
CAPACITY TO WIN, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT I ENVISION A
COUNTRY WHERE WE JUST GET AS
SICK AND AS TWISTED AS SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE COMING OUT
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
I REFUSED TO DO THAT.
I REFUSE TO BELIEVE THAT
SOMEHOW WE CAN'T EVER --
LIKE WE ARE GOING TO SPLIT INTO
RED AMERICA AND BLUE AMERICA IN
A PLACE LIKE MICHIGAN, THAT
DOESN'T WORK.
IN OUR OWN FAMILIES IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
I WANT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO
FIX THEMSELVES.
I CAN'T FIX THEM, RIGHT?
WHAT I CAN DO IS WIN AT THE
BALLOT BOX IN A WEEK.
THAT IS WHAT I AM TRYING TO DO
AND AS SOMEONE WHO IS A FORMER
CIA OFFICER AND PENTAGON
OFFICIAL WHO DID THREE TOURS IN
IRAQ ALONGSIDE THE MILITARY, I
WOULD PUT MY WILLINGNESS TO
FIGHT AT MY SPINE AGAINST
ANYONE RUNNING ANY OF THESE
BLUE BLUE STATES.
WELL THAT'S HOW YOU SELL IT.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD ANSWER.
THAT'S A PRE